le gouvernement russe envisage de
déclarer l'état d'urgence nationale
peut-être l'une des annonces de vladimir
poutine qui doit s'exprimer aujourd'hui
devant la population russe à face aux
coronavirus et pour soutenir l'économie
du pays la russie elle va débloquer plus
de 16 milliards d'euros parmi les
mesures déjà annoncées et une aide aux
petites et moyennes entreprises le
premier ministre a également annoncé des
mesures de soutien aux régions russes
souvent très dépendante de l'aide
fédérale afin de compenser l es pertes
budgétaires et plus d'informations avec
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
gayraud désormais le gouvernement aura
la possibilité de déclarer l'état
d'urgence afin de coordonner et
d'encadrer des mesures d'urgence pour
faire face aux défis liés à la
propagation du cornât virus le texte
prévoyant tout un barème d'amande pour
les violations du régime de quarantaine
entre autres a également été ratifiée
lors du conseil des ministres qui s'est
au passage tenue en visioconférence le
premier ministre a également annoncé le
déblocage de 1400 milliards de roubles
environ 16 milliards d'euros pour lutter
contre la pandémie de kobe 19 mais aussi
pour soutenir l'économie
elle mêle on peut citer le report de
différentes cotisations le soutien aux
personnes insolvables ou encore des
subventions à destination des régions
russes afin de compenser les pertes
budgétaires liées à la baisse de leurs
revenus
sinon sur le front sanitaires se sont
aujourd'hui en russie plus de 3500
personnes qui sont contaminées pour 30
morts selon les derniers chiffres
officiels des chiffres qui incite
certaines voix au sein du gouvernement a
demandé la prolongation des mesures de
confinement